hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast improving methodological
quality of animal experiments are we
doing all we can I am Brenda Kelly Kim
of lab roots and I'll be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots the leading
social networking site for science
professionals for more information
please visit www you can submit your
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many of your questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon and lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. new no
Franco nunu Franco is a biologist and
postdoctoral researcher at the I 3s
University of Porto laboratory animal
science group and an external advisor
for laboratory animal science at the
University of Lisbon's IMM his research
focuses on laboratory animal welfare
along with ethical legal social and
scientific issues and animal research
his research interests also include
translational science science
communication and education is currently
setting up a national network animal
welfare bodies in Portugal I'll now turn
it over to dr. Franco for his
presentation thank you brother thank you
all for
attending this presentation so I'm
talking about celebratory mechanisms in
regarding animal research and how these
have contributed to on doing brew
principles and practice and I'll address
some some current issues with this with
this self regulation so a very quick
overview of this presentation I will
start by addressing the issue of quality
of research as an ethical imperative so
the main factors for the conditional
acceptance of animal research the
current state of your guarding animal
use based on my previous work well
translate ability as a cause for
opposition to animal research and this
is why we should address it as much as
we can and of course retro disability as
a condition for present ability they
don't move on to address the issue of
full methodological quality and what we
are have been doing to to tackle it and
I'll close my presentation by getting a
few remarks on how to deal with this
systemic problem in a systemic fashion
so we all know that the advent of
scientific medicine is intrinsically
connected with animal research since at
least the 19th century so vaccines
antibiotics in saline anti-cancer agents
and aesthetics you name it all of those
um benefits from medical research have
resulted from proper use of animal or
animals in science it's quite revealing
that eighty-two percent of all Nobel
laureates and medicine and physiology
since in 1901 have been given to
researchers using animals and this
includes all Nobel Prize prizes since
1984 but as you are low and more
research is an ethical issue
however there is a current social legal
next unethical view on the acceptability
of animal research which is based on a
cost-benefit a perspective and by post
we mean by the harm we put on animals we
but this is a mainstream position that
is far from being consensual and there
is a considerable public debate about
I'm experimentation so we as scientists
working with animals we are working
under a social licence this license is
that's it rather than deliberate but we
should have in mind that using animals
is more of a pretty privileged than a
given right so and this privilege
warrants that the public trust that our
work is relevant competent and ethical
so I'm going to give you a very year and
quick overview or how the public forum
then will research and this will be
important on the justification of why
you should you should do or we can to
improve on the benefits from animal
research and minimize harm so you have
too many initial additives which are
approval in this approval of course and
the key factors are homes to animals and
benefits of research the thing is there
is a part of this society that focuses
largely or solely on harm so on there is
no value conflict and you can't do
anything to convince them otherwise so
this means will remain I'm disapproval
and then we have on the side of the
other of those will approve conditional
approval so no one approves of animal
research giving a car launch two on two
researchers so this approval does Lauren
have no alternatives are are available
and the animals are respected it might
happen that some of the disapproval when
faced with more information and with
a few case studies where Harmon benefit
are in conflict might shift and become
more reserved and approve on animal use
on a case-by-case basis and this might
happen also with those who start off by
being approvers and then when they do
know that there is no are some issues
with animal welfare and with the
translate ability of adam research so
those who are initially whose can become
reserves as well so it's always
unconditional the acceptance of animal
research showing it it must aim at
gaining scientific knowledge improving
health and safety of humans and other
animals of course and it won't at all
efforts are made in order to minimize
harm to animals and of course that these
conditions are due reinforced by
legislation and adequately supervise so
starting from the first premise our
animal experiments benefiting human
health so it's hard to argue from what I
just said they did animal experiments do
not contribute to up to human health but
there is evidence piling up that most
animal research does not translate into
clinical benefit and even worse most
animal research is not reproducible or
because of unaccounted biases so roughly
ninety percent of compounds that are
deemed promising in animal studies will
fail clinical trials this might be due
to a number of causes but the chances
are it's more than just one cause so it
includes publication bias battle
methodological shortcomings some
problems with species differences and
constant validity issues but the thing
is we
cannot know how informative a given
animal model is until we eliminate the
noise caused by methodological problems
so should we mind the model or the
method I'm giving you an example which
is taken by a large study that involved
around 18,000 animals carried out by the
Meo traffic lateral sclerosis therapy
Development Institute they retested over
50 drugs almost 60 drugs that were
deemed quite promising in in critical
preclinical trials but failed miserably
in the clinical setting but they did so
properly what they found and this is the
effector who had been reported in the
literature but they found when they
carried out adequately powered properly
randomized blind tests that the effect
was simply not there so does this mean
that the animals were such good models
that if we carried out the experiments
correctly they would mimic the clinical
setting well it doesn't work the other
way around so the thing is we don't know
we just don't know we just have this
huge confounding factor and the bias of
animal experiments from methodological
problems that prevents us from making an
informed assessment of the translational
value of these models one of the
problems is the interp owling of
experiments we all know that the power
of an experiment is the probability of
finding an effect if the effect is
indeed there if there is an effect and
because of low power we fail to detect
it so animals will be wasted and group
size should be determined on a
case-by-case basis
a very quick example if we have a good
comparison by these tests and we are
seeking a thirty percent increase in
survival we observed there is a standard
deviation of forty percent and with very
standard conditions of eighty percent
power and an alpha of point 05 the
recommended websites would be 23 animals
but the this largely use number of
almost magical number of 10 animals
which is quite arbitrary for this bini
for these conditions will only give us a
fifty percent power so we have fifty
percent chances under these conditions
that if there is an effect we wouldn't
find it and the problem is in the
neurosciences the mean power has is
between eight percent in thirty one
percent and this is indeed a problem and
moreover because with such low power one
we do find an effect chances are this
effect will be exaggerated and then when
we try to reproduce the experiment we it
will tend to give more modest results or
even no results at all which we call the
new winners curse so we definitely need
more power in animal experiments just a
shout out to all the Star Trek geeks out
there another issue is like a random
assignment of animals to groups and
blinding to the outcome so not all
animals are created equal so if we don't
randomize the animals to the the
treatment groups we might end up having
cage effects or later effects or any
given effect that is given by any
characteristic which is shared by the
first animals that pic pick up and put
in a group and the last items that we
can pick up and put in another group
another problem is lining of service to
the scientific help them up come into
the experimental groups and the control
groups and these have been reported to
have an effect of up to twenty percent
on the outcome so this is why I value
what
all was published in brain and they
measured the report an improvement in in
fact volume in studies that had
randomized animals two groups aniston
studies that had carried out blindness
invited assessment and they did find
there was a voice that was evident so we
are not accounting for this in most of
the published literature when a plural
carried out a systematic review of 290
animal studies that had been published
in them and the proceedings album of a
conference over the over the years they
found that non randomized unblinded
tests ended up reporting ninety percent
of positive results when we properly
randomized and blind the outcome only
sixty-eight percent so there is a large
part of the effect that is reported that
is resulting from these unaccounted
biases so let's move on to the second
premise that animals are treated you
mainly um I'll just make a very short
presentation of my previous work I
carried out them to systematic reviews
one on animal models of Huntington's
disease and another one on me run models
of tuberculosis two very different
diseases but the results are quite a
quite the same what I found in the
literature was that there was a
significant rising trend in papers
reporting ethical approval protocols or
the following of animal care guidelines
but when I went on to classify the
severity of these studies and you see
these are dotted lines they mean um
level four studies which under the
current legislation would be deemed
above thresh
because animals are allowed to die
instantaneously of the disease or reach
comatose point we don't observe any
significant change over the years and
moreover it was more likely that a very
severe study had been approved by an
ethics committee then then otherwise so
forty-two percent of study specifies
that as level for admin reported
reported ethical approval most of them
had a lot of animals to die
spontaneously and for the Huntington's
disease case study 57% had reported
ethical approval of level four studies
you can know more about these studies in
these papers published in PLoS ONE Adler
and loss pathogens so what does this
mean firstly that we are far from making
all efforts to minimize suffering and
this is a sentence that we see we
currently in the literature but chances
are it's meaningless when we actually
look at the methods and how long it was
carried out and also that we are sending
the message that it's ok to allow
animals reaching end stages and dying
from the disease and second that ethics
committees approve of studies being done
this way so there are actually reasons
to be concerned about how when why and
what I used in science and it does
become difficult to argue in favor of
animals permits from a scientific and
ethical point of view if the public has
no clear understanding of what benefits
may result from it what is being done to
minimize harm and how is this regulated
and supervised and I presented some this
issue in this issue in them this paper
honor on admin
and this is quite important because in
Europe we had over 1 million signatures
for a European citizens initiative to
stop animal use this they called it
strategy section it was supported by
several members of the European
Parliament and the petitioners rejected
the three hours all of the three are
because they can say they legitimize
animal use and they demanded a repeal of
legislation and we are talking about
them I'll go arguably the most advanced
legislation to protect animals used for
scientific purposes it also means a
shift and the approach by
anti-vivisection is from violent attacks
and targeting of scientists to lobbying
and trying to work with within the
corridors of power and another important
factor was that rather than focusing on
harm they were focusing on semi
scientific arguments regarding the
usefulness and the informational value
of animal experiments and our vote was
rejected by the European Commission they
are far from finished so they do stated
they will carry on pursuing all civil
political and legal means to stop and we
use regardless of the benefits that
might be gained from it what we mean by
benefit this is almost a quazy
philosophical question but the thing is
we already have some mechanisms for the
evaluation of benefit we have the
evaluation of funding applications that
ultimately will judge whether a given
animal experiments is well your funding
or not and we of course at the peer
review of manuscripts for publication
potential
excuse me benefits are much harder to
explain to the public for instance in
basic research and the thing is the the
unwanted biases and the low quality
methods in science are hindering the
likelihood of benefit even further the
European Commission proposes that
potential to achieve the intended
benefit it's considered one of the
factors when evaluating animal animal
projects and if you see here this last
square the third one on the right you
will see that even if the intended
benefit is high and the arm to animals
is no if the likelihood of benefit is
also low so if there is no
methodological quality that will ensure
that we will gain sound data from the
study the project should not be approved
so this is important what mechanisms
regularly mechanisms do we have to to
help us address this issue we are all
acquainted with external regulation we
have legislation we have in Europe and I
apologize for being so on your century
we have European director we have
leftover law which is the transposition
of the directive and we also have funded
we do not tend to see funders as
external regulators but since they
didn't give a value and give funding
based on meritocracy based on what they
perceive is a valid use of animals they
also act as external regulation internal
regulation starts by meijer my
individual scientists in a long shot
choice of species and methods and also
as a scientific community as a whole so
when we are peer review is where
we follow journal policies on animal
years when we write or follow community
guidelines on animal use we are self
regulating and then we have mechanisms
that are a mix of the of the two because
they are legally imposed but ultimately
carried out by peers and we have in this
regard profit evaluation and training of
researchers to carry on animal
experiments we are we have two projects
running here at our lab one of them is
focusing on external legislation
legislation which is the framework
project funded and impact and the other
one is my own postal grant which is
focusing on into internal regulatory
mechanism eckin isms and their impact on
animal research when i talk about
methodological quality i'm talking about
both the soundness of the experimental
design and respect for animal welfare
and both of them can be improved my self
regulation so let's focus primarily on
scientific community guidelines on
animal use and taking the ALS community
as an example the the purpose of
guideline from the scientific community
can be more directed at animal welfare
and these include guidance documents
lying by charities such as the SPCA your
uniform or other sections of the
scientific community we also have
guidelines on the quality of reporting
so you can integrate the results from
animal experiments in into systematic
reviews and have a larger assessment of
of the the evidence for let's let us say
over drug efficacy and also to to have a
better understanding of the results that
are presented
and then we have valid lines to improve
the scientific soundness of the result
and these include general guidance on
experimental design on statistics on
broadly used techniques and guidelines
that are more field-specific such as the
guidelines from the ALS community and
knowing about the pervasive effect of
horrible methodological quality 22
guided sets of guidelines have already
been published by the amniotic lateral
sclerosis research community one in 2007
and another an update in 2010 I'm not
very quickly any atrophic lateral
sclerosis is a rapidly progressive at
fatal motor neuron degenerative disease
most patients will die between two and
five years after the first clinical
signs the incidence is five times higher
than that of Huntington's and every year
eleven thousand new cases appearing in
in Europe it's characterized by
increasing muscle rigidity muscle
twitching increasing and worsening a
weakness from the decreasing muscle mass
as the motor neurons the January and
eventually difficulty speaking following
and reading the mouse model the most
common mouse model use the steel the saw
one g93a it's a den genic model with a
mutation for the copper zinc superoxide
dismutase enzyme which is associated
with around twenty percent of the cases
of familial ALS however only ten percent
of ALS cases are familial and the rest
are sporadic so we have a construct
validity of the model
right there the onset of disease in
these are models can vary from lab to
lab from strangest rain and also the
rate of progression but roughly by 120
days you'll find a gate and abnormality
and which will quickly move to two old
solid Parise's and complete paralysis of
the hind limbs and we'll move on to
complete paralysis which is the Morrigan
stage and then respiratory failure as it
happens in the clinical setting with
patients the standard on point in the
which is proposing the guidelines is
euthanasia of animals that can no longer
resume the right right position after
being placed mostly recumbent I have a
short video here just to show you these
these mites so it doesn't become too
abstract and you have a grasp of the the
motor difficulty of these mice you
please play the video these are 20 week
old mice bearing assault of a mutation
in already showing paralysis of the hind
limbs sod1 minds only represent the
fraction of familial ALS cases but their
phenotype shares several similarities
with ALS with different etiologies I'd
like to draw your attention to the
orange match foot on the cage floor to
allow animals to eat and hydrate as they
become unable to reach the food hopper
not doing this will result in
malnutrition and dehydration becoming
comorbidities that add noise to the
outcome so we developed a purpose may
severity classification scale to
classify the severity of these studies
where level 4 is roughly equivalent to
the conventional and endpoint so animals
are euthanized
they lose the ability to write himself
within 10 to 30 seconds after being laid
recumbent or when they lose fifteen to
twenty percent of the peak weight and
level five as those studies that would
allow animals to die spontaneously or
reach complete paralysis which usually
precedes death by a few hours and these
studies considering the recurrent
legislation in the EU would be
considered above threshold so above the
severe classification so to understand
the impact of these on guidelines we set
out to do carry out a systematic review
of published studies on this model and
we collected data on self-reported
regulatory compliance on animal welfare
based on the severity that other animals
were allowed two to reach the
implementation of humane endpoints and
any other model specific refinements
such as that the adding of mesh food to
to the cage floor we also looked at the
quality of one of reporting of methods
of animals on housing and husbandry and
basic scientific standards such as
justification for the sample size
randomization of animals two treatment
groups and blinding of service and to
evaluate the impact of the guidelines we
reviewed papers published both before
and after the publication of set
guidelines so we reviewed papers
published in 2005 9 11 and 13 we ended
up with more than three 1304 lapse
tracks after the first three hours and
ended up being 1970 787 and after second
three hours we found three hundred and
eighty eighty two full
original research papers to review this
data was entirely collected by Jonathan
and who also paid out a lot of the
analysis regarding reporting of relevant
research parameters and good practices
we found that Bree clinical studies
which were the studies that were
explicit explicitly stated to to be
carried out to test a given treatment
were more much more likely to report
useful information such as number of
transit copy sex of the animals genetic
background group size and justification
for for the group size and especially
for the random assignment of our animals
to treatment groups and for the blinding
of observers we did find found that a
preclinical studies upheld much higher
standards than piece of concept studies
however although group size was are
highly reported only two percent of the
studies we review justify the numbers
used and we were only satisfied with
around two more three papers out of 382
so no good news again there regarding
group size we found that ninety-one
percent of preclinical studies those who
were supposed to uphold the highest
standards of ninety-one percent of those
use fewer or much fewer animals than the
absolute minimum recommended by the ALS
guidelines but we did increase within
report as an increase in self-reported
regular compliance especially the
approval of protocols by an ethics
committee or an equivalent
however only 15 of the papers published
after guidelines on explicitly stated
following the vlsi lines on which by the
scientific community severity was not at
all affected by whether a paper was
reported to be approved by an by an
ethics committee so if the study was
approved by an ethics committee we
didn't find any any impact on the
severity and most studies either before
or after the application of the
guidelines use the conventional end
point so but a a surprisingly low
percentage of them a lot of animals to
die spontaneously or reach complete
paralysis however only ten percent of
studies where animals manifested overt
motor dysfunction reported any
enrichment or any cage adaptation to
allow animals to eat and drink or even
move and neither time nor the revelatory
compliance status appears to have
influenced the use of these refinements
we did find some country differences in
the incident of highly severe studies so
if we look at these on of these reps
will find that neither in Canada nor in
the UK and surprisingly not also not in
China no study was allowed to to allow
animals to reach a level 5 severity and
we found a high incidence of these level
5 very high in severe studies in Israel
Japan
and Korea so a brief discussion of these
results only twelve percent of these
studies were classified at the highest
severity level and the use of a single
model is likely a factor in the bodice
emanation of an any point and whether
this conventional endpoint was already
broadly used before the first guideline
so the guidelines reflected what was
already common practice rather than
proposing or promoting earlier end
points and it's revealing that
self-reported regular compiles had no
overall impact on severity and we did
find a higher severity of preclinical
studies of a proof of concept and just a
quick note on these standard end points
which are applying at very late stages
they are at least two papers reporting
earlier end point that correlate nicely
with with later end point so these could
be applied in future guidelines could be
good contemplate these these end points
once they are more thoroughly validated
so regarding likelihood of benefit the
sample site is what much lower than
recommended this is apparently in line
with a principle of reduction but only
are only apparently really because and
the powered studies might lead to
unreliable results and ultimately to
animals be and being wasted as well as
resources we found higher mettlach
methodological importing standards in
preclinical studies but thing is all
animal studies should be helped to hike
scientific standards and the lack of
cage and a patient's is worrisome
because it can affect results you have
the confounding effect of starvation and
dehydration in survival data it also
allows to increase external validity
because patients are
provided palliative care so it mimics
more closely what happens in the clinic
so the take-home messages from this work
is that the community guidelines have
not yet influenced how research is
carried out or reported and other self
regulatory mechanisms must be in place
to promote kai-lan compliance them and
these guidelines must uphold higher
animal welfare standards as much as
scientific ones because as I told you
previously even if the intended benefit
is high if there is lower likelihood of
benefit and great harm to animals the
research is unacceptable so moving on to
journal policies on animal use journals
can be important regulators of how
research is carried out in reported
because authors scientists are motivated
to publish their results and this is
particularly true for high impact
journals so if a high impact journals
lead the way in promoting in their
policies animal welfare quality of
research and improved reporting of
animal experiments chances are authors
authors would feel more motivated to
comply with SIA with such guidelines
journals are increasingly adhering to
guidelines on reporting of animal
studies and especially the arrive
guidelines but the editorial policies on
animal welfare and ethics are much more
diverse and even frequently absent from
journal policies but we wanted to map
journal policy so we picked up this
acronym for excellence in editorial man
due to military policies on animal
research and develop the exemplar scale
to classify editorial policies
the key features of this clip is that it
ranges from 0 to 20 and it that divides
80 your policies into four main
categories namely regulatory compliance
quality of research and report your
results any more of an ethics and
integrity lien for the exclusion of
papers based on the other three criteria
for each category we define a good
standard or an ideal criterion which is
worth five points if journals did not
observe that ideal criterion the some
about tentative criteria for this
category could award up to four points
and we decided that some items would
have more weight on the final score than
than others so if journals demand offers
to to give a proof that the study had
had underwent ethical approval or any
kind of project evaluation the policies
from the journal will be given a higher
score for that category then if they
only asked authors to state compliance
with relevant guidelines or legislation
for instance an example for from the
completely bogus journal of biological
stuff and whatnot which has an example
score of nine what can we learn from
this fall we know that there is no
criterion for the exclusion of papers so
if authors do not comply there is
nothing explicitly stated in the god in
the Big Island or authors that the
manuscript will be excluded there is a
high relevance given to compliance with
regulations and some importance placed
upon issues regarding quality of
reporting and
and ethics you can know more about the
example school school and it's used as a
tool to classify throw your policies and
in this paper published in animals so we
set out to classify a sample of 170
journals published publishing studies
animal studies in on type 1 diabetes
tuberculosis or els we chose these
fields because we firstly we think they
are representative of a lot of the
preclinical research that is that is
being carried out but also because we
are carrying out systematic reviews of
animal welfare and soundness of methods
in these in these fields so this will
allow us in the future to what to
compare the score of the of the journals
and the the principles in practice as
revealed in the papers that these
channels are publishing seventy-two
percent of the 170 journals in our
sample were scored less than eight
points radha me and more than ninety
one-percent scored less than tangle so
there are a lot of them of journals that
have very low demanding policies on
animal use if we look at this by
category in and feel the research we can
see that for category one reporting of
regulatory compliance ninety-two percent
of journals have some policy on the
compliance to regulations by my office
when we look at on quality of research
and reporting seventy-two percent of
journals in our sample had no policy on
this issue and it's even more worrisome
for policies on animal welfare and
ethics and on the existence of any
criterion for the exclusion of papers
based on lack of compliance by office we
didn't find any differences between
fields country or journal antiquity
neither for impact factor of the
journals we did find however that open
access journals scored significantly
higher than subscription-based journals
so in short most scientific journals are
mainly concerned that authors just state
compliance with laws and regulations
rather than having an active role
promoting best practice and also that
journals are disregarding their role in
self-regulation of animal research and
diverting it to institutions and
regulators there is room for optimism
Omaha and this just in this was
information which was published this
week actually that that tells us that
there is a surge in support for animal
research guidelines and specifically the
arrive guidelines I'll just jump back to
show you here category B where we find
this a small spike here in in this the
cottony between those studies those
journals that don't have any policies on
walking over of data from animal studies
and those journal that have that had
five a five score which was mainly
granted to those journals that are
referenced office to derive guidelines
so there is some effect of the right
guidelines
and more than 600 journals now with the
office due to these guidelines however
there is no evidence that there are
guidelines being referenced in the
journal policies actually have an effect
on the quality of the information
available in the papers that these
journals publish so this is reason for
concern there is also room for optimism
regarding animal welfare and attention
to animal welfare issues oh this very
recently in September 2015 nature made
the authors of the paper not retract but
correct their their paper based on a
breach of their license and they stated
as well as writing to grab that paper to
mark the breach of anamorphic guidelines
the office apologize for the beach and
they are like to do so cases such as
this could provoke a justifiable
backlash against animal research so all
involved scientists institutions funders
and journals must do more to ensure that
regulations are strictly observed I
actually consider this to be a big deal
well even though it formed a complaint
rather than the editors or reviewers
initiative even though no animal welfare
concerns were identified during the
courage and in the correction on the
paper and even though the journals
general policies on animal welfare
remain unchanged they did change
something very specific about maximum
tumor size that offers are allowed to to
report nothing major and compliance with
regulations remains the central issue
and just due to give you an idea the
nature's example school which is 724
regulatory compliance 54 reporting over
of the information because they
reference office to the arrive
guidelines and no policy lot whatsoever
animal welfare and ethics aside from
this later policy on tumor size and no
explicit policy on the exclusion of
papers based on lack of compliance to
journal policies so future directions
there are a lot of self racketeering
mechanisms I have already covered
editorial policies and community
guidelines but due to the issue that we
found we are carrying out a survey to
editors on their views regarding the
policies in the interplay between
policies and the role of the editors and
reviewers regarding animal welfare
ethics three hours and qualitative
research we also carry out carrying out
the systematic review of type 1 diabetes
models so we can cross the information
between the policies and the actual
standards as reported in the papers and
regarding self-regulation what else can
we do so scientists have a role in
particular uation of course in training
other researchers in an animal use and
when we are reviewing papers for
scientific journals and this will affect
the researchers choice of species and
methods and back in back and floor so
it's a dynamic interaction between
regulation and principles and practice
so change comes from within so what I
propose is that everyone should educate
themselves on sound experimental design
a good starting point is this this
website by Michael fasting and it has an
old-school vibe but it's a very well
structured and easy to comprehend site
and you can learn the basics on
experimental design sample size
calculation and you would be good to go
and you also have some some quizzes to
self-evaluate and i recommend italy i
recommend it bibili i am urge you to
review your own methods and make sure
your students do too and then especially
because we are not born knowing how to
resign and analyze scientific
experiments also go for my professor
angle um if you can establish regular
training in experimental design in your
Institute the best one I I think think
of is the one which is carried out by
fray the courses on reduction and
experimental design by the fun folder
and replacement program and multi
medical experiments which despite the
name focus on all of the three also
replaced the production and and
refinement I suggest that you take a
look on this paper by am dr. Derek fry
on how to teach experimental design how
to develop courses that can go from an
afternoon to a three day course or a
doctoral program module and I urge you
to apply these standards when you peer
review so be demanding regarding animal
welfare and refinement the detail in
reporting so if there is no sufficient
information
regarding animals husbandry expect to
design the hypothesis many stated
statistics sample size requested from
from off the rover's make sure that the
authors did what they should do to or
should have done to avoid bias by
randomization by blinding by declaring
also conflicts of interest but being
demanding does not necessarily mean
rejecting manuscripts why is it so well
firstly this is what we think authors do
when they reject the manuscript that
they will give up and they acknowledge
there that the manuscript has several
flaws that they should have done things
differently but what actually happens is
that they just try to submit it
somewhere else some somewhere that will
have lower lower standards so it's much
better to be constructive so if and what
information is Miss is missing requested
if authors did not randomized or do not
report written by randomization of
minding of all of service to to the
outcome they should report it so and
chances are sums in some case if you
find out that the office actually did
that and just fail to report it
regarding animal affair if there are
major concerns do ask for the license of
limitation if the animals were given
palliative care of gauge nesting or any
adaptations this should be reported and
also if not so we can have an informed
assessment of the survival data if
animals in your unnecessary harm
discussed this with the editor we got
incentive incentive Excel pneus if the
sample size of the methods are flawed
suggests more conservative conclusions
and discussion of study limitations so
in a nutshell regular
division of animal years are important
and necessary but obviously they are
insufficient the same goes for the
ethical appraisal of our experiments but
it would be impossible and injectable to
have researchers under permanent
scrutiny so we can't and in my opinion
we shouldn't have a policeman in every
lab so each resurgent must also become
its own regulator so are we doing all we
can to improve methodological quality of
animal experiments based on the data
that I presented to you well not really
but we can do much better and it's only
through researchers responsibility both
as individuals and as part of a
community of a large extended community
that significant profit products can be
achieved regarding the humane treatment
of that other lab animals and the
reliability and rebel disability of
animal research we can't expect and more
needed to be translatable to the
clinical setting if we can't even ensure
that we can replicate it in other
animals so rapid disability must proceed
translate ability of animal studies and
no single solution will do the trick
because we are part of an ecosystem so
we have to address what i consider to be
a systemic problem systemically I just
urge you because animal rights activists
when people wanting to stop medical
research are focusing more and more on
the methodological shortcomings on
animal research and the lack of
translational value I urge you to please
don't make them right and also as
someone who is deeply involved in
talking to the public in
media with students in schools and i
have a blog i write in newspapers just
today I had a not bad in the
international newspaper on animal
research and pros and cons and
advocating for humane and scientifically
sound animal research I urge you to
please don't make me wrong so a few
acknowledgement of course to Michael to
my post our supervisor and Olson to my
crew supervisor Peter Sango and a hike
Alma teens we who carried out a lot of
land of the analysis for the journal
policies review Jenna Fernandez who did
most of the work for the ALS case study
all of my of my group who pitched in
when we needed the Olympic team what we
society full of animal files full for
all the other all their help and of
course these two ranking bodies the FTT
and the fp7 framework for being kind
enough to give me money to carry out my
research and thank you for for listening
thank you dr. Franco for that
informative presentation before we get
started on our question and answer
session I want to remind the audience
how to submit their questions you can
submit questions for dr. Franco by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button lower left of the presentation
window will try to get to as many
questions as you can this is a great
topic today about animal welfare lab
animals and experimentation we probably
have a lot to say we'll just give you a
few seconds to find the green button
type in your question and dr. Franco
would be happy to talk about anything
you have comments or questions on
you
and think I think we must have some
questions coming in from our audience
here in just a few minutes okay perhaps
not perhaps our audience is on to
another one of our presentations I would
just like to thank dr. Franco again for
his time today bringing us this
important presentation this webinar is
going to be available on demand on my
roots calm through August of 2016
attendees today will receive an email
alerting them when this webcast is
available for replay and we would
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues I want to just turn it
back over to dr. Franco or any final
comments you might have on his
presentation for our audience well I
just wanted to thank you all for
attending and if you have any pressing
questions do contacted contact me too to
my email that you can find in the left
right corner and i'll be glad to to
reply thank you thank you again dr.
Franco would also like to thank lab
routes comm for making this web seminar
possible we hope to see you again in one
of our presentations that's all we have
for today thank you very much and
goodbye